la grille de départ et les deux pilotes
sont un endroit après le grand prix de
san marin à imola
ils ont tout simplement parce que le
français alain prost est une que son
coéquipier le manque de loyauté à son
égard visiblement leur querelle pourrait
amender sur cette saison de formule
miracle grand prix 200 marines one c'est
de réussir chez le guardian
la cohabitation au sein de l'écurie
mclaren autre soleil tranche du plan
dans l'aide n'est pas non agression
passé entre les deux pilotes qui voulait
que le premier tour les deux hommes ne
s'attaquerait pas n'a pas été respectée
le premier virage est nord 2-1 position
a passé trente personnages qui paraît
s'être apaisée
voilà qui confirme en france estimant
que la conseil d'éthique n'a pas été
respectée pour équiper quelque chose
semble dans les rouages
mettre au service d'une hauteur des
rennais en coûte à l'acronyme la cote r
inutilement irrité preuve l'un des
pilotes pourrait décider de claire
cavalier seul pour ambition dans
l'écurie mclaren
autre hypothèse le français pourrait
bien tirer un trait sur sa collaboration
avec mclaren au terme de son contrat à
la fin de cette année